[Aplausos]
[Música]
china e india- concentrada una tercera
parte de la población mundial sin
embargo aunque parezca imposible estos
países tienen amplias zonas de
territorio donde no vive absolutamente
nadie y una de esas zonas es
precisamente la frontera que separa
estos dos países
[Música]
hablamos de 3500 kilómetros que cruzan
los himalayas y donde apenas hay
asentamientos humanos vamos está el yeti
y poco más en otras palabras que los
chinos y los indios comparten fronteras
pero se ven muy poco las caras y por lo
que vais a ver a lo largo de este vídeo
casi mejor que sea así porque cada vez
que una patrulla fronteriza china y una
patrulla fronteriza india se cruzan lo
habitual es que se llamen de todo y se
guíen a puñetazos y no esto no es una
metáfora es muy real
hablamos de peleas a puñetazos limpio
son mucho más habituales de lo que
podríais pensar
hablamos de dos países que llevan
décadas de malas relaciones y eso es
especialmente preocupante si tenemos en
cuenta que hablamos de dos naciones que
concentran la tercera parte de la
población en otras palabras que noticias
como esta nos asustan a todos porque
podrían ser el inicio de una tercera
guerra mundial
[Música]
20 soldados indios muertos en los
primeros enfrentamientos mortales con
tropas chinas en 45 años y os
preguntaréis pero por qué se llevan tan
mal los indios y los chinos pues lo
cierto es que sería más fácil decir por
qué no se llevan mal la frontera que los
separa es objeto de disputas perpetuas
fijaos en este mapa elaborado por al
yazira
y una frontera oeste es donde ha tenido
lugar el choque actual la parte en azul
marino es cachemira parte de cachemira
está controlada por pakistán y la otra
por india en azul celeste está el
glaciar se ha arrebatado por la india
pakistán en naranja está la zona de
aksai chin controlada por china y que
también reclama la india allí en galván
valley es donde ahora se ha producido
ese enfrentamiento mortal pero esperad
un momento porque el resto de la
frontera también es un auténtico
polvorín en el este está el estado indio
de arunachal pradesh reivindicado por
china como territorio propio desde que
ocupó el tíbet y entre nepal y bután hay
una pequeña franja de tierra que es el
antiguo reino de sikkim que también hace
frontera
[Música]
fue justo en esta zona donde se
enfrentaron tropas de china y la india
en 2017 y se enfrentaron como es
costumbre habitual en esta zona a
puñetazo limpio y repito esto no es una
metáfora hablamos de uno de los pocos
casos del mundo de conflicto violento
pero no armado todas las luchas son
cuerpo a cuerpo pero ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando en serio de verdad me
está diciendo fonseca que solucionan sus
problemas a puñetazos pues lo cierto es
que si puñetazos y diplomacia en el año
2017 el presidente de china xi jinping y
el primer ministro indio narendra modi
se reunieron en una ciudad china para
intentar poner fin a estos conflictos
parecía que todo iba a salir bien pero
lo cierto es que todo es a buena onda y
ese buen rollo ha desaparecido y es que
hay ciudades en china que parece que
atraen la mala suerte porque si mis
queridos amigos de visual política a que
no adivina es entidad china decidieron
organizar esta cumbre en el año 2017
pues aspectos
el primer ministro modi destaca que el
espíritu de buján ha dado un nuevo
impulso a los lazos entre india y china
exacto empujan parece que este acuerdo
estaba maldito desde el primer momento y
ahora en 2020 las tensiones entre china
e india- vuelven a ser primera página de
todos los medios al igual que la ciudad
de buján así que la pregunta de hoy es
hasta qué punto puede haber una guerra
abierta entre china y la india que puede
pasar con toda esta tensión fronteriza
de verdad estamos ante las puertas de
una tercera guerra mundial hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
un vuelo de colosos china india son dos
civilizaciones que tienen vínculos
culturales religiosos y comerciales
desde hace la friolera de 2500 años a
priori no están condenados a ser
enemigos pero la realidad es que se
llevan fatal sobre todo desde que china
ocupó el tíbet en 1950 y entonces
pasaron a ser vecinos ya compartir
fronteras pero por qué tanto odio pues a
ver lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
explicar el tíbet es un territorio tan
remoto como inmenso
sí ya lo sabemos el tíbet está donde
buda perdió las zapatillas pero es tan
grande como sudáfrica aproximadamente el
doble del tamaño de francia si fuera
independiente sería uno de los 25 países
más grandes del mundo pero como os
podéis imaginar es una zona
prácticamente despoblada porque ya me
diréis vosotros quién se va a vivir al
tibet dos habitantes por kilómetro
cuadrado para que os hagáis una idea esa
es la misma densidad de población que la
que hay en el sáhara occidental sin
embargo el trazado de sus fronteras es
exactamente la principal causa de
confrontación entre china y la india
desde hace siete décadas porque como ya
os podéis imaginar como tantos otros
conflictos internacionales los problemas
vienen una vez más de los tiempos del
imperio británico
como ya hemos explicado en anteriores
vídeos de visual política china imperial
siempre ha tenido influencia sobre el
tibet pero a comienzos del siglo 20 la
ciudad prohibida de pekín no pasaba
precisamente por su mejor momento así
que los británicos aprovecharon la
debilidad china e invadieron el tíbet
sin embargo su interés no era quedarse
en la región así que los ingleses y el
dalai lama' llegaron a un acuerdo el
dalai lama' gobernaría un tíbet
independiente y a cambio los británicos
extenderían sus dominios del rey
británico de la india a costa del
territorio tibetano cuál es el problema
pues que por aquel entonces no existía
'google earth' y los británicos tienen
un jaleo de mapas terrible pensando bien
como trazas una frontera en el himalaya
si no tiene satélites pones un mojón en
la cumbre del everest y qué pasa con las
aduanas donde las pones puede parecer
una tontería pero definir fronteras en
una zona tan montañosa es casi imposible
y todo eso explica que haya tantas
regiones en esta zona del mundo que son
prácticamente tierra de nadie
[Música]
en la frontera occidental la de
cachemira había mapas británicos que
decían que aksai chin era territorio
dentro del dominio del imperio británico
de la india pero en otros mapas no lo
decía y la confusión sigue hasta
nuestros días simplemente echado un
vistazo al mapa actual la zona rayada
que veis es tan grande como suiza
oficialmente es parte de china pero sin
embargo india la reclama
[Aplausos]
más clara es la situación en la frontera
oriental en el año 1914 reinó unido- y
tíbet firmaron un tratado que definió la
frontera nordeste de la india británica
de acuerdo con lo que se conoció como la
línea mcmahon quedaos con este nombre
porque va a ser muy importante durante
el resto de la historia esto suponía que
el tíbet entregaba la región de
arunachal pradesh a la corona británica
la rural pradesh es un poquito más
grande que la república checa- y el
doble de la controvertida zona aviacsa y
sin os digo todo esto para que os hagáis
una idea de la magnitud del problema
el caso es que china protestó y mostró
su desacuerdo por el trazado de esta
frontera pero cuando la india se
independizó en 1947 adoptó la línea
mcmahon como su frontera con el tíbet el
dalai lama estaba de acuerdo pero de
nuevo china no y mucho menos desde que
el régimen comunista ocupó militarmente
el tíbet de 1950 y la línea mcmahon pasó
a ser la frontera directa entre los dos
países este nuevo mapa político iba a
enfrentar dos intereses contrapuestos
por un lado la aspiración china de
respetar las antiguas fronteras de la
china imperial por el otro los
nacionalistas hindúes querían conservar
las fronteras imperiales británicas
porque les daba mucho más territorio
durante la década de los 50 ambos países
procuraron evitar el conflicto directo y
más o menos respetaban la línea mcmahon
pero la tensión volvió al máximo nivel
en el año 1959 si habéis visto en
nuestro vídeo sobre el tíbet recordaréis
que ese es el año en el que china
reprime las protestas en el tíbet y es
en ese momento cuando el dalai lama huyó
del tíbet por la noche y donde se
refugia exacto en la india como os
podéis imaginar esto no le hizo la más
mínima gracia a china y todo esto
explica que en el año 1962 se librará
una guerra entre india y china china
barrio de la zona a los batallones de la
india sin embargo el conflicto tuvo
pocas consecuencias territoriales en la
frontera occidental china consolidó su
dominio de acc sightseeing pero el
oriental se retiró de las zonas
conquistadas de arunachal pradesh y
retrocedió hasta la linea mcmahon que
hoy en día sigue siendo la frontera
entre ambos países y desde 1988 china e
india se han estado reuniendo varias
veces para renegociar esta frontera sin
embargo nunca han llegado aún
por otra parte tampoco se atreven a
volver a enfrentarse pensadlo bien
india es una potencia nuclear y no las
armas nucleares no son sólo para
defenderse de pakistán atentos a lo que
en su día le dijo a bill clinton el por
entonces primer ministro de la india
[Música]
tenemos en nuestras fronteras un estado
con armas nucleares reconocidas un
estado que cometió una agresión armada
contra la india en 1962 aunque nuestras
relaciones con ese país han mejorado en
la última década más o menos persiste
una atmósfera de desconfianza
principalmente debido al problema
fronterizo no resuelto atal behari by
spain primer ministro indio entre 1998 y
2004 en otras palabras que china e
india- estar en lo que llamamos un duelo
mexicano es decir se odian a muerte pero
no se atreven a iniciar un conflicto
armado porque ambos tienen armamento
como para aniquilar se mutuamente
y diréis cómo han resuelto esta
animadversión pues de la forma más rara
que os podáis imaginar a puñetazos y de
nuevo esto no es una metáfora en los
años 90 china e india- llegaron al
acuerdo de que sus patrullas fronterizas
pueden insultar se pegarse o escupir se
pero sin usar las armas y por
sorprendente que os parezca este acuerdo
ha funcionado bastante bien durante
décadas los soldados indios y los chinos
han podido desahogarse sin que eso lleve
a ninguna escalada militar mientras
tanto china india se han podido entrar
en cosas un poco más importantes
principalmente crecer económicamente
para que os hagáis una idea tres décadas
más tarde de estos acuerdos chinas se ha
convertido en la fábrica del mundo y la
india en el proveedor de servicios del
mundo si quieres fabricar cosas te vas a
china si quieres contratar programadores
de vas a la india puntopelota los dos
países han crecido como si no existiera
mañana y los conflictos territoriales
han pasado a un segundo plano así que
ahora os preguntaréis y qué ha pasado en
el año 2020 para que este conflicto
vuelva a tensionarse pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
y el collar de perlas todos lo sabemos
el mayor antagonista de china son los
eeuu pero si alguien puede darle un
dolor de cabeza de verdad a china es la
india si seguís visual políticas de hace
años ya lo sabéis en anteriores vídeos
de este canal ya os hemos contado lo que
es la diplomacia sugar daddy de china
pero os voy a hacer un resumen en los
últimos años china no solo ha invertido
en su iniciativa welt and road la
llamada nueva ruta de la seda también lo
ha hecho en el llamado collar de perlas
los que nos veis desde hace tiempo ya lo
sabéis muy bien china depende en gran
medida de sus importaciones de materias
primas por ejemplo el 80 por ciento de
sus importaciones de petróleo pasan por
el llamado estrecho de malaca y eso
significa que tienen que pasar muy
cerquita de esta ristra de islas que son
las islas de andamán y nicobar estas
islas están pobladas por una tribu que
apenas ha tenido contacto con el mundo
exterior la tribu de los sentí ingleses
prácticamente no le importan a nadie
pero sin embargo tienen algo muy
y pertenecen a la india por supuesto que
nunca veréis a un policía indio pasando
ni de lejos por estas islas pero
legalmente sobre el papel son territorio
indio y eso significa que la india puede
mandar a su ejército por esta zona
cuando le dé la gana y atentos porque
bastaría con que la india desplegar a su
armada por el mar de andamán para cortar
el tránsito de todo tipo de buques por
el estrecho de malaca de repente china
se quedaría sin petróleo y sin muchas
otras materias primas y por eso china ha
desarrollado su estrategia del collar de
perlas
esta estrategia consiste en una
inversión multimillonaria en diferentes
países con acceso al océano índico los
yuanes de china buscarían dos objetivos
muy entrelazados el primero sería
endeudar a estos países de tal manera
que no pudieran rechazar una alianza en
defensa de los intereses estratégicos de
beijing el segundo objetivo sería
desarrollar puertos marítimos en el
océano índico que en principio no
tendrían carácter militar pero que ahora
habían llegado al caso la debilidad
económica de estos países y su deuda con
china harían verdaderamente complicado
que tuvieran capacidad para decirle que
no a beijing en otras palabras que lo
podrían militarizar a esta estrategia en
visual política la llamamos en su día la
diplomacia del sugar daddy go es decir
por un lado yo te pago todos tus
caprichos pero a cambio te hago total y
absolutamente dependiente de mí así que
china ya ha desarrollado un collar de
perlas para rodear a la india con sus
puertos en sí blanca maldivas pakistán
bangladesh y somalia
[Música]
como os podéis imaginar todo esto no le
ha hecho la más mínima gracia a la india
en primer lugar porque como os hemos
explicado la rivalidad que sienten hacia
china es enorme desde la guerra de 1962
y en segundo lugar porque ven a china
como una amenaza para su crecimiento
económico de hecho la india ha rechazado
unirse a un acuerdo comercial entre asia
oriental y oceanía por miedo a abrir más
sus mercancías a los productos chinos en
nueva delhi consideran que el déficit
comercial con china ya es muy elevado es
decir que la india compra china mucho
más de lo que vende y esta tendencia es
más aguda año tras año pero no sólo eso
tanto si blancas como maldivas
bangladesh o incluso nepal son países
que la india considera como su área
natural de influencia están cerca y
tienen muchas relaciones tanto
culturales como comerciales con la india
durante décadas
[Música]
de este modo el collar de perlas es
visto por la india como una intromisión
de china en su diplomacia y por si todo
esto fuera poco la guinda del pastel es
la amistad entre china y el archienemigo
indio pakistán en otras palabras que
cada vez hay más razones para que la
india y china- se lleven a matar y todo
esto explica que a ese collar de perlas
chino nueva delhi haya respondido con su
collar de diamantes una serie de
alianzas con otros países de la región
para permitir a la armada india acceso a
algunos de sus puertos hablamos de
países tan dispersos como omán
seychelles iran singapur o el último
pero no por ello el menos importante
indonesia atención a este puerto en
sumatra porque sería fundamental para
poder cerrar el estrecho de malaca
base militar india en sábana indonesia
puede estrangular a china en el estrecho
de malaca pero ojo porque la india ha
buscado apoyo es mucho más allá del
índico ha fortalecido a la alianza quad
que incluye a cuatro potencias recelosas
del despertar chino
hablamos como no de la propia india
australia japón y eeuu y hay que
recordar que india está rompiendo con
décadas de una política de no alineación
respecto a los bloques globales una
neutralidad que están claramente
abandonando apostando directamente por
el bloque liderado por eeuu washington
ha tenido siempre unas relaciones muy
frías con la india especialmente desde
que desarrollaron su armamento nuclear
pero ya ha pasado bastante tiempo y
ahora sí en la casa blanca tienen que
elegir lo tiene muy claro se decantan
más por el curry que por la soja
por supuesto todos estos lazos entre
india y eeuu también molestan a china
pero sin duda alguna la mayor afrenta
para beijing es el apoyo que le da la
india a la causa tibetana el dalai lama
como sabéis vive en la india y es el
enemigo público número uno de china así
que como veis ese espíritu de buján es
más un fantasma del pasado que una
esperanza para el futuro y cuando
parecía que las relaciones entre estos
dos países no podían ir a peor
la tensión se recrudeció en la de
cachemira ahora mismo os lo vamos a
contar
[Aplausos]
la tercera guerra mundial albert
einstein decía que no sabía qué armas se
usarían en la tercera guerra mundial
pero sí en la cuarta palos y piedras
pues bien parece que no iba muy
desencaminado atentos a estas imágenes
de finales de mayo de 2020 manos
al final
nuevos
no
y estos soldados son del ejército de la
india y acaban de interceptar en su
territorio a un blindado ligero del
ejército popular de liberación chino y
como veis le han recibido como si fuera
el inspector de hacienda le estan
apedreando y obligando a retroceder dos
semanas después de que se difundiera
este vídeo se dio a conocer el
enfrentamiento mortal de galp one bal y
las bajas chinas no se hicieron públicas
es más en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo todavía no está muy claro si
los soldados indios murieron apaleados o
de hipotermia tras caer a las aguas
heladas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
lo que sí está claro es que estamos ante
el choque más relevante décadas entre
china e india ahora bien por qué pasa
esto ahora pues veréis la india tiene un
gobierno ultranacionalista una de sus
medidas más polémicas ha sido la de
quitar a cachemira su autonomía han
venido a decir que en cachemira no manda
a nadie más que nueva delhi y se han
dedicado a reforzar sus posiciones en
china todo esto se ve como una amenaza a
la región de axa y ching que domina
baking y honestamente no es para menos
india ya ha movilizado tropas cerca de
la frontera y no creáis que hablamos de
unos pocos soldados para que se haga una
idea y ya ha construido un aeródromo a
5000 metros de altura con la pista de
aterrizaje más alta del mundo y también
han construido carreteras como ésta
[Música]
[Aplausos]
esta carretera haría más accesibles las
posiciones fronterizas para el ejército
indio y parece ser que esto explicaría
el interés chino por el valle de galo
one
la proximidad al enlace de la carretera
daulat de hold y hace que galván sea
vital y por su parte china aprovechó que
el mundo estaba más pendiente de
pandemias que de invasiones y ocupó unas
60 hectáreas que pertenecen a la india
un movimiento así es toda una
declaración de guerra sin embargo
esperado un momento porque parece que
china dio un paso atrás después del
choque mortal y ha abandonado sus
posiciones de vanguardia y diréis pero
hoy porque ha actuado así beijing pues
muy posiblemente para darle un aviso a
la india pensadlo bien hace décadas
china y la india eran dos países
igualmente pobres hoy en día sin embargo
la economía china multiplica por cinco a
la india por supuesto que india ha
crecido muchísimo estos años pero es que
china ha crecido muchísimo más y eso
tiene su reflejo en el presupuesto
militar china en un ejército muchísimo
mejor armado que el de la india
sin embargo la india sigue contando con
un as en la manga sus aliados de nuevo
eeuu es más propenso a ayudar a india
que ayudar a china en otras palabras que
seguimos en una situación de duelo
mexicano india y china- se odian pero no
están dispuestos a un enfrentamiento
abierto
ah
y diréis y esta vez cómo van a resolver
todo este odio pues bien si hace décadas
la respuesta fueron los puñetazos y los
escupitajos ahora están optando por algo
un poco más civilizado la economía de
momento india ya ha prohibido tick tock
güiza y otras 50 aplicaciones que vienen
de china además se está planteando
imponer aranceles a más de mil productos
cuál es el problema pues que dentro de
la india hay quien quiere evitar una
guerra comercial porque piensan que
causaría más daños a la propia india que
a china sin embargo también hay
empresarios y empresarios de peso que se
han puesto del lado del gobierno mira
sin ir más lejos lo que dices ihan
jindal presidente del grupo jsv doble
jota sw es uno de los conglomerados
industriales más grandes de la india
atentos muchos de mis amigos y ccoo
industriales están molestos porque sus
negocios con chinas son necesarios para
mantener márgenes saludables y
continuidad pero esta situación se debe
a nuestra complacencia en aceptar
ciegamente importaciones más baratas de
china en lugar de desarrollar nuestros
propios proveedores nacionales
continúan las conversaciones entre china
y india sobre heladas así que seguiremos
atentos a próximos acontecimientos pero
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
creéis que finalmente veremos una guerra
entre china e india o tal vez todo se
quedará otra vez en puñetazos y
aranceles podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios mientras
tanto no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a visual política y darle la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]